you good fit that's no way to treat yes
Greg I'm sorry Andrea I was just quoting
the Black Widow trailer from before you
got 15 through what the hell are you
doing I'm copying you
taskmaster you know Andrew I tell people
my sister moved out west
your science teacher your husband even
of these houses you're thinking about
moving but you're gonna waits until the
interest rates go down I was on my story
right kind of fight fine was an Avenger
I mean mistakes
enemies
[Music]
his call sign is telling us about our
bad - he controls the Red Room they're
manipulating
any conscious adult choices
I should have come back for you the
others are there
go back to Arnold story
so they never do that to anyone again
with you
we won't win
[Music]
Wow very funny
my plan was to drive us away land sucks
[Music]
whoa
Oh
[Music]
the ratios
I don't mind
and she runs
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
she was probably drinking vodka so now I
guess happy Hogan can't just say how
does cap do that he's gonna stay at his
Alexia rate guardian throw the shield
like that when did you think of that
joke while we were watching this trailer
it just came to me that is very
impressive all right well the biggest
takeaway that I have from this specific
trailer all the family dynamics
specifically this line at the very end
when Red Guardian Alexei says listen to
your mother there's a Captain America
Civil War deleted scene she says that
she went to like the grave sites of her
parents an end game when she's talking
with Red Skull did the moms not mention
but she's like the Red Skull says
father's name is Ivan and she said she
didn't know who what his name was this
is having me be skeptical a little bit
questionable towards this as I'm going
okay they gonna die in this movie even
though that's a deleted scene in Captain
America Civil War
does that make that deleted scene still
kind of Canon and linear then does that
make it factor into it this movie's
gonna be I don't know thoughts from the
gang I mean it mostly it made me wonder
if this was some kind of surrogate
family type deal where like you know
this is the family that you gained when
you're through the Black Widow program
and these are the people who basically
become your new life because I have to
assume that all of these shadowy Black
Widow type organizations take you and
then separate you from your old life and
give you an entirely new life you know
that's kind of what I would imagine for
that otherwise it would just be kind of
confusing to me to have like two random
sets of parents harping off what you
said I did like the family dynamic to it
I mean we did see in the first trailer
she did call you Lena sis obviously I
don't expect them to be biological
sisters I expect because they trained
together in the Red Room really watching
this trailer or really was like it
already getting invested in there really
just like how close they're getting like
in in serious moments I think that
relationships gonna be meaningful on top
of the you know milena and Alexi that
looks really endearing and you know the
action just looks really sick and I like
to like in the first shot how how it
shot the scope of its very cinematic II
and it's just it looks great I really
love it and again the action the
hand-to-hand combat it's something I'm a
huge fan of it looks like we're in for
something really cool took a really big
page of the Russo brothers except for
like crazy
that's a hell mess of it all oh yeah you
know you thought teases of the other
black widows and the other trailers then
here really looks like that taskmasters
main villain and all the crazy henchmen
are really gonna be all the black widows
you do see this footage were taskmasters
watching Black Widow from Iron Man 2
who's showing that he's been studying
her moves for a long time maybe that's
how he learned to mirror her movement
from watching like surveillance footage
which is a cool thing to add in here I
keep wondering though because of the
fact that none of black widows family
family I don't know if it's quotes or
not yeah but because none of them showed
up in other films or there's even
mention of them there's that line in
endgame that she has she's like I never
really have a family until the Avengers
what if they betray her in the end
that's it anything yeah yeah because
that's one of the few things that I
think would actually justify it because
it would be weird to leave off in a
positive place with these people and
then not ever enough what's them again
especially because they're leaning so
heavily in the marketing towards the
family dynamics they don't really show
you a lot of Rachel Weisz and in these
trailers
I mean she's Academy Award nominated
Rachel vice they call her mother in this
trailer she seems like she's probably a
much more important character than the
trailers are really letting you see I'm
sort of getting this impression that she
has some treacherous thing up her sleeve
that might hold influence over Alexei
and Yelena
because they're trying to mask stuff and
I'm just trying to figure out what it is
that they're really masking because I
agree like everything we've talked about
from all the black widow trailers still
holds and it's still very really
prevalent here like the action does look
great it looks like there's gonna be
some really funny family dynamics as
well when you think about like certain
things of
Meishan that have been brought up in the
other movies it starts to make you a
question what this family might actually
end up being so you're thinking we might
get a little Dark Knight Rises were a
little betrayal their little Talia al
Ghul don't bring up DC movies Wow
watching a Marvel train vice versa you
got fat I could see that happening there
obviously they're not showing us you
know a whole lot of the family dynamic
other than then it's in a positive place
and like you said in Avengers endgame
you know she said that the only family
she ever had was the Avengers I could
see something like that happening I mean
not obviously you know be a twist of the
knife or surfer yeah they go out of
their way in this trailer to call
taskmaster a man who has trained all the
black widows and stuff like that so
partly if I'm just sitting here you know
speculating my I do appreciate the
theory that yeah maybe it will be Molina
who is treacherous in some way but they
also catch Ray Winstone he's not in any
of these trailers he's not as I don't
know him to be as fit as taskmaster yeah
looks but again that is an actor who's a
pretty decent status and who we've seen
none of for this movie so I wonder how
that's gonna play in and if he might be
cast master in some way shape or form I
know we're trying to figure out who
taskmaster is my theory is that there's
multiple people who dawn the taskmaster
identity in this one we also got to see
a Dee aged Thaddeus it makes you
question the timeline cuz it looks even
younger than he did in the Incredible
Hulk after Civil War it's supposedly
what do you think about the theory that
it is actually Clint in the taskmaster
outfit if this is after Civil War
wouldn't make a lot of sense because
after infinity war maybe I might leave
no suffice to that very true I don't
know where this thing is with this
family I don't know why he'd be off
doing it yeah both remember Budapest
very
[Laughter]
this perspective I'm hoping to in this
film speaking of Budapest I'm hoping we
do possibly get a flashback in Budapest
maybe we'll get a flashback I think
you're in Buda Buda they shot it there
you mean like go to the action a
flashback with her with her in class oh
yeah and that three times also hoping I
don't think we're gonna get this but I'm
also hoping we get to see the Winter
Soldier Bucky give her the slug in the
side you know because she mentioned that
in Winter Soldier oh yeah I don't think
so but I'd be cool if we did that's the
point
be cool see a little flashback like that
Black Widow did you get your tickets we
haven't we should probably get on top of
that what are your predictions for this
movie are you excited for it I think
this look this looks really cool
regardless of whatever main big plot
fields are gonna be I feel like the
immediacy of the action and the
characters and Florence Pugh dipping in
and out of her accent is gonna be great
she pulls a real Scarlet Witch subscribe
to the real rejects click that
notification bell and I lost my loose
lips on this with a scuba Steve you're
an artist you're creative so I wrote you
a Greg poem here we go I'll dance a hoop
around a hula for my man named scuba I'm
a dumb dork who constantly thinks he's
from New York
when it's actually a Rhode Island I'll
make up the Lion by sending you some
diamonds never meant to see if his first
name is actually Steve more handsome
than Keanu Reeves ladies
that's something you should actually
believe find a wall spray paint the
mouse named Mickey maybe you won't get
in trouble with all the graffiti and
ladies might be more inclined to leave
their mark with a blasted on Hickey I
use your stories to lie to some lawyers
you're a big fan of horror never leave
our patreon page or else I'll become a
mourner I want to go to bed now Steve